if you think you know Johnny 49 from
Alabama is gonna stop me cursing you
have no idea how I grew up you got your
perspective there's this level of not
understanding the importance of the
scaled creative and more importantly the
way I think about it there's gonna be a
culture of making I gave you on my heart
but did you even notice it every verse I
write I put my heart the biggest thing
that I want to accomplish a answer any
detail question I want to really do that
these a skills like hey this is nothing
to work here because I don't see how you
know like that's what this is about but
the other thing is for everybody
understand like deeply why this is gonna
happen with you without us it's live and
literally if we all disappear tomorrow
like no Boehner I I quit you quit we all
quit no Vayner this model is going to
win the day in this industry in 2021
let's promise me promise so I just wish
it's us it's us once you actually see
it's just hard to see because they
everything else feels like sleep when
that record label ain't calm ain't
perfect but I'm more than what you asked
for
I got fans why the hell I'm feeling sad
for all I ever wanted was a platform
audition for meat mills management
[Applause]
let me let me let let me talk you've
been waiting two [ __ ] days for this
[Applause]
sorry about that what I'm fascinated by
is that everybody here how many people
here have been following me for more
than one year raise your hand the fact
that 90% of this audience knows that all
I want you to do is run Facebook and
Instagram ads and you still aren't makes
me want to punch all of you in your
[ __ ] face I mean literally all I've
been asking you to do for the last two
years is run Facebook and Instagram ads
and you [ __ ] face is still art and I say
this because I put it on film because
I'm gonna run this exact video against
you in five years on some platform
telling you that you missed the golden
era of Facebook and Instagram because
now it's appropriately priced and you
guys have heard me if you follow me say
this I regret that I wasn't able to
build my dad's business bigger because I
didn't spend enough on Google I didn't
spend enough I had it figured out it was
called Google Adwords
it was working yet I still was doing
newspapers and Direct Mail and radio and
television because I didn't understand
the context of the moment that I was
living on and they just laugh when I
said my name was Nick I went home
feeling sick but knew I couldn't quit
but
they know that God granted me this gift
that was broken on my pockets but my
mind was feeling rich
[Music]
what should you miss money about in you
you know hardness be making money being
you I get it but you want you don't want
to just talk then you wouldn't care
about how you're growing like if you
didn't want you want to do something
else with it yeah you don't want to just
talk otherwise if you just want to talk
to be happy as [ __ ] cuz you're talking
sod it yeah you got to be patient
by all about sure can I was love up see
it yeah like this is a question thank
you yeah yeah got blue ski you have so
pretty much thank you for coming thank
you so much thank you thank you thank
you so much I'd love to talk to you
you'd say thank you so much I hope you
enjoying it thank you you're very you're
PA hey how are you hey day very well
first when I felt it
inspiration thanks for coming I hope you
enjoyed enjoy this butter yeah bad
another oldie I love you you're welcome
hey thank you how are you thanks so much
you're welcome
hope you like that promo video thank you
thank you Travel huh I will wear it I'm
aware of this thank you so much
Cheers thank you so much man tickets
gonna hear oh thank you very thank you
so much hi thank you for your question
how are you good thank you how are you
good thank you Cheers my man you didn't
brother we listen thank you so much to
stay well
thank you love it d-roc I got but top
tucked good walk and talk pleasure
those three friends obsessed with such a
pleasure thank you thanks for coming
thanks for Kari can I ask a quick
question
wait
that work how are you buying nice to see
you how are you thank you how are you
performing right no are you time thanks
for selling boat cheers how are you man
I'm all the best to you take care thank
you for coming thank you for coming
stay well Seto ever you I know I'm
flattered very good thank you come in
nice to meet you
I thank you for your question how are
you
given the Duke vena learn there's some
work for mental health would you like
we're doing stuff ahead of deep line so
thanks for coming man it's fun watching
to your question of course thank you
very much he's so happy I got but I call
it thick fingers my company view each
other to see you thank you thank you my
friend such a pleasure thank you this
for me bureaucracy
share the gift like a penny where you're
soft nice to meet you guys how are you
so much okay
thank you thank you man stay well hi hi
are you a huge piece together dentist
yeah totally awesome I'm a big fan I
made a black one that I didn't tell
anybody about that I'm gonna put out
maxin I will they took it I enjoyed it
thank you how are you
thank you brother to say what I should
buy thank you thank you brother
I'm tree wants for you I'd like a mental
online yeah I don't see ya
I'm very good thank you
hi Ayten I are you doing you so thank
you thank you
all right fine yeah thank to the Mantha
sailor you know
thank you so much maybe we just say
hello to everybody unspoken that's what
diary dude thank you brother
thank you very odd a there you go thank
you
[Music]
well I gotta bounce
welcome so much guys bye
welcome
awesome eight five guys loving this way
no way this way and then Philip how do
you feel about Gary swearing so much she
cursed her ass off when I was a kid it
was mom mom yeah but mom I understood
Russian my mom would call us you know we
were a tease baby so we're outside
playing she would call us she would call
us we didn't want to stop playing and
then she would say one thing and I mean
it didn't matter didn't matter if it was
bottom of the ninth two outs bases
loaded in a game if that one phrase came
out I was in the house within a minute
because I do what was on the other side
of that one but my mom doesn't play that
was real [ __ ]
punching punishing slapping slapping mom
did you slap there was a there was a
belt that hung over our seriously there
was a I laugh like but people like to
think about like being sad it like
people's comments or when people would
tell me like cursing like I'm like you
have no idea how I grew up if you think
you know Johnny 49 from Alabama is gonna
stop me cursing
thank you so much very good
wiU poems
I can company put a whiskey thank you so
much a little yeah hello you see Russian
speaking we can probably target people
in Brooklyn who would great word of
mouth for your moscow event you know
here we go thank you so much
hello hello how are you yes thank you
mom you want some thank you thank you
how are you thanks for joining thanks
for coming how are you thanks for coming
this is awesome this is nice
thanks for joining me
thanks for coming man thanks appreciate
it hey brother
thank you it was really nice
this is [ __ ] fancy I know I know like
it's a long way from Belarus some kid
comes up to me at the airport I'm on my
way to the Jets game in Cleveland last
Thursday which did not work out so I'm
still upset and he comes up to me and
goes Gary I can't believe I'm running
into you I'm from Canada I just was here
and I had the worst day of my life I was
scammed out of all of my inheritance
and I just came to New York and it's now
done I'm a hunt I've been scammed out of
all my money and I looked at it he's
very young guy and I looked them and I
was like and it was interesting where I
went with it cuz I'm a very
compassionate dude but was interesting
uh which is why I'm excited for him my
natural reaction was more snarky than
coddling which is usually my default I
said cuz you wanted to make too much
money too fast and he looked at me I
mean I knew nothing I've talked to him
for two seconds he goes I've been
scammed out of all my inheritance and I
said cuz you wanted to make too much
money too fast and he goes you're right
and I was like of course I'm right it
was interest I never had this kind of
inaction I said of course I'm right
people don't get scammed out of their
inheritance unless they're going for
something too good to be true whether
it's cryptocurrency which I'm very
concerned about cuz we were getting
ripped off for a million other things
but it's interesting nobody pushes
patients more than me
out of the truth of how I lived my life
and to even if I didn't much like I
don't read or diss an act or I don't
meditate it's just very obviously works
I think one of them
steaks that a lot of people do when
they're trying to make a spread on a job
is they're trying to drive down the cost
of their overhead to make the spread
she's willing to pay me 50,000 I'm gonna
hire him for 17 bucks an hour him for 18
he wants 22 but I [ __ ] me 12 this and
that because that's how I'm gonna make
11,000 I think the way to do it and I
don't know all the details yet but I'm
listening is to create a base and
incentivize the upside which creates
more scale so you say to these two you
want 22 I'll give you 32 if you get it
done in 24 hours what you're doing is
what one of the things that back to old
school this is my dad never wanted to
pay anybody because that was where the
margin came from but then he D
incentivized anybody to care correct so
I think one of the ways to do it is go
the other way and establish a
performance-based model that makes less
margin in the beginning for you but by
establishing pro-worker
you build a reputation and a brand that
brings you more and then you can create
your scale well Mike what my dad did
extremely well was he built a discount
business that he didn't make as much
money as everybody else but he made it
up in volume he might have made $1.00 or
maybe others made 3 but by being a the
cheapest he sold a hundred cases of that
rom versus seven and I think one of the
things you need to think about is create
performance hurdles that if everything
if him and him and that crew were so
good if they crushed it you would only
make 5 percent margin but they were
thrilled and they start turning down
everything else which allows you to do
four jobs at 5% instead of one job at 15
do you see where I'm going so what you
do is you create a more incentivized
model it makes less margin for you but
then you get the best people who are
making more money off of you you sit in
the middle should try it
thanks mom this is my destiny
this is God's plan even if you get the
best of me done no no that acquits
estimate
knock me down let you pass you say
wonders when you laugh you live when
you're in a family business loving each
other more than the money always works
that's the boss that's the boss for
every twenty twenty-five year old a
couple things one you have to be patient
to if you're lucky enough to have this
kind of beautiful hair if you dominate
the world three most people twenty
twenty five disproportionately value
other people's opinions and live their
lives based on that like away from that
it would be blown away by what can
happen for shipping what do you want you
tell me buddy
you're the Munn life do something with
it exactly a period Alexander I'm very
upset that you're not here I have no
idea why you're not here I'm baffled yes
we're very disappointed in you and
others in this I mean very glad I'm not
playing against you because I'm very
emotional when it comes to poker not in
business number two and this is
important actually because a lot of
people you know I grew up in the u.s. I
was older than a lot of the kids that
went poker exploded a lot of kids that
blew up if you're watching right now and
you're under up food if you're under 30
if you're 33 and under 33 to 25 please
understand that your ability to be
successful in poker I've watched a lot
of you half of you go to the dark side
and use that capability to do dumb [ __ ]
half of you haven't figured out how to
go to the bright side but I will say
this if you're a great at poker you
already have the pieces to be great at
life you use that to do good not bad
that's good
one judgment is poisoned don't judge
others don't let them judge you and
truth it always wins in the end I think
the biggest confusion right now in
society very simply is that people see
people doing the wrong thing and they
think they're winning they're only
winning of half times good always wins
in the end I'm in stop of it true right
please I would like that I want to hear
an action yes something missing brother
thank you
these are [ __ ] good and I think you
deserve a better pictures in your
Instagram I agree d-roc terrible
pictures you rock your fire look this is
my destiny
this is God's plan even if you get the
best of me yeah this is my destiny
this is guys praying even if you get the
best of me done